Joel what he got the number is 9600
square feet 9600 square feet that would
be a big house bigger than my own it's
bigger than my Oh miles big it's the
home that a developer said that he might
build on the property behind Mark
Zuckerberg property with with it with a
wonderful view of Mark Zuckerberg his
bedroom yeah he didn't actually tell
Mark Zuckerberg that he would be looking
into his bedroom but emails produced in
the case that we're talking about
indicate that that's that's a story it
can happen the story will agree is a guy
buys a house right behind Mark
Zuckerberg recently purchased house and
then sends him an email and says you
know what as a favor to you neighbor at
twice what I paid I'll let you buy some
of that property so I can't see in your
backyard when I build my new McMansion
yeah a piece of the property a kind of a
buffer to afford him the privacy that he
thinks he deserves as a the the two
negotiated there's some kind of dispute
about you know what that negotiators
about but in the end
Mark Zuckerberg bought the entire
property and yet this guy says that mark
didn't do what he said he was gonna do
he didn't make good on
he claims he that Mark Zuckerberg didn't
make good on a kind of a critical piece
of the deal which is a unwritten spoken
agreement to introduce this developer to
some of Mark Zuckerberg contacts you
know business contacts friends it's not
exactly clear who those people would be
but that's the part that he didn't do
and that's the kind of core of the
dispute mr. kudos New York your take you
know it's easy to sort of look at this
and sort of feel an awful lot of Shatan
pride and say you know privacy not
making connections these are all things
that you know you know marks maybe with
some people would feel good about having
had happen but you know what I just find
this kind of predatory stuff just
depressing you know and it's what people
don't realize is how widespread it is
the instant someone has an exit in the
tech industry people like this literally
fall out of trees and out of your
backyard with all kinds of claims and
showing up and try to find some you
serious path to end up with a claim
against you and it's really awful and
it's just getting worse because of how
much more visibility
people have so you know I may not be
sympathy sympathetic to mark in general
but this specific story is just the tip
of an iceberg that's really awful right
now it does sound like you've got a
litigious guy who's just trying to get
into his wallet but could have been wor
than that Paul real quick
no I don't think so I think a loose
claim where a loose promise was you know
likely made and as a result now this guy
felt like he has an edge and he's
prepared to exploit it to the Mack